foreign
nice to see you here today I'm Jason
Taylor I'm a solution architect in
Brisbane for a company named increment
and I'm also a Microsoft MVP in
developer Technologies I'm excited to be
here today at the Copenhagen developers
festival and I'm even more excited to be
presenting my new talk unleashing clean
architecture in.net 8. now this is very
much a show and tell style talk I'll be
showing you how to use my clean
architecture solution template show you
how to set up your development
environment how to create a new solution
how to build test and run the solution
locally and how to use the built-in
pipelines as code and infrastructure as
code to deploy the solution to
production
I'll also be telling you about some of
the features that I've included in the
template which have been designed to
enable you to focus on delivering
business value rather than setting up
new Solutions setting up projects
setting up infrastructure and pipelines
let's get started
so the clean architecture solution
template provides a simple and
straightforward approach to Enterprise
application development with clean
architecture and asp.net core
now it's easy to get started it's a net
project template and that means you can
run it from the command line using.net
new or from Visual Studio 22 file new
project
it's been built on.net the original
version was released in October of 2019
on.net 3.1 and it's been upgraded to 567
and the largest upgrade by far has been
to.net 8. now if you're looking at
starting a new solution in anytime now
dot net 8 would be a great choice that's
the long-term support release and as the
LTS release that's mean it's going to be
supported in production for three years
now we should receive a go live license
in about one week and then the official
release for net 8 will be in November at
dot net conf
so with the.net upgrade there was a lot
of new features that I added that were
requested by users of the template for
many years so one of the first and
biggest ones was support for multiple
front-end Frameworks so we now support
angular react and web API out of the box
I've also added support for multiple
databases I've started with sqlite and
SQL server but I'll be looking to add
postgresql quite soon
now you know there's been a lot of
changes with the asp.net core templates
in regards to authentication and
authorization.net's been quite a big
upgrade so I've adjusted my templates to
align with those changes so I've removed
uh dewandi identity server and using
this simple approach now with asp.net
core identity for angular and react and
also the new identity API for the web
API only solution
one of the really big things was
implementing a full CI CD pipeline as
code and also infrastructure as code
because I want users of the template no
matter what level they're coming from to
have a good chance to do things right on
day Zero so using this template you can
establish a new CI CD Pipeline with
GitHub actions and deploy the solution
to Azure using bicep templates I've also
included scripts so that it makes sure
that GitHub Azure the resources and the
credentials all get set up for you
and of course the template is still
freely available on Open Source on
GitHub so if you do find it useful
please give it a star
all right so installing the template is
straightforward you can do that from the
command line.net new install Clean
architecture solution template now the
current version of the template is a
preview version so you'd need to specify
the version otherwise you'll get the.net
7 version but I'll show you that
now once you've done that you can create
a new solution just by going.net new ca
solution
there's a few options that are available
in the template so you could specify the
standard options the name the output but
also the client framework so this is
where you can specify either angular
react or none if you'd prefer a web API
Only Solution you can also specify that
you'd like to use sqlite by default it
will use SQL server but if you choose
sqlite then that's that's fine and
that'll work across all different
environments
so the example there is creating a new
react front end with an asp.net core
backend it'll be called cph Dev fast now
because it's a.net template it does some
really cool stuff when you create a new
project it's going to use that folder
name the output directory cph Dev Fest
as the solution name and it'll also have
namespaces cph defest but remember
there's pipelines as code and
infrastructure as code in that template
as well and so that means those
pipelines and infrastructure are going
to be customized with cph defest as well
so when you download this and create a
new solution you're pretty much ready to
go
so if you want to create a new solution
using visual studio 2022 just install
the template and then that that project
template will be available in the create
a new project dialog so very easy to get
started
I want to jump into the first demo so
the first demo we're going to prepare
your development environment
we'll create a new solution make sure
the template's installed make sure
you've got the correct version of.net
installed we'll build it run it test it
and then deploy it to production because
we uh we don't want to waste any time
with this one right
all right so I'm going to jump into
Windows terminal
and the first thing I want to do
you probably wish me luck it's quite a
lot to do but hopefully with the
template it's all automated fingers
crossed I'll check the.net version so if
I go.net version
8 preview seven so we're on the latest
version so if you don't have the latest
version you can go off to dot dot net
and grab it I also want to make sure
that I've got the GitHub CLI installed
and this is going to be used by one of
the scripts that will set up the Azure
resources that's great and you know what
I might as well go ahead and create a
new GitHub repo while we're at it so
let's go GitHub repo create I've got
some help there cph deadfest will make
it a public repository and we'll clone
it straight away
there we go so we can jump into cph Dev
first and we can go GitHub browse
and we can see that repositories ready
to go
okay so we want to install the clean
architecture solution template so as
mentioned it's net
install Clean dot architecture dot
solution
dot template and we need to specify the
version because it's a preview version
so I think we can just go
eight star now if that's already
installed that's off to a good start
file was not found.net new install
there we go
if it's already installed it's just
gonna it's just gonna reinstall it for
me make sure everything's right so you
can see there's two templates there
there's the ca solution which you've
already looked at and then there's the
ca use case so this has got some item
templates in there to help you generate
use cases to make it a little bit easier
to build the functional idea that you
that you'll need to build and we'll have
a look at those a little bit later but
right now I want to create the new
solution so we're in that c h cph Dev
fast directory so we'll go.net new
uh CI solution client framework we'll
choose none we'll go with web API just
could it'll build a little bit quicker
for us
and so that creates the solution so we
see we're ready to go we've got an Azure
directory which includes all of our
bicep templates we've got a GitHub
directory which includes our GitHub
actions we've got a scripts directory
which will help us set up our CI CD
Pipeline and all the Azure resources
then we've got source for our main
projects tests for other projects and a
whole bunch of other files there
so the first thing I want to do is build
this so I'll run.net build TL
and TL is the new
modernized build output and so you can
see there it's kind of doing this inline
build if there's some issues it'll show
us
more specifically where their where the
issues have occurred so it's not this
big wall of text anymore which is which
I think is quite nice
I'll just take a little while to get
through this first build
it'll go ahead and um add support for
open API so it's going to build a
specification as part of the build
but once that's done we'll go ahead and
run this solution
let's go
okay
there we go
okay so if we go ahead and run the
solution first I just need to jump into
the web directory so we're going to
Source start web
.net run
okay so this is a web API only so it'll
just launch the solution and we can have
a look at Swagger UI so we're not going
to get too much into the details of the
UI or anything like that just to make
sure that it's running
there we go
okay
so I'll go ahead and run the tests
there's a whole bunch of test projects
built into this solution to help get you
started on the right foot whoops CD back
CD tests and so you can see that I've
got some application layer functional
tests unit tests some domain unit tests
and a placeholder for your integration
tests
so if I go.net test
and we'll just go no build make it nice
and quick so we just want to make sure
everything's working right before we go
ahead and deploy this thing to
production so I'm just doing some sanity
checks it makes sure that my development
environment set up correctly but really
we want to that's not good oh that's
Docker all right
one thing I forgot to do
we want to make sure that this is going
to be okay and that everything's in
place
so I'm pretty confident so let's go
ahead and
add those files
and commit
this is a new project
okay now before I push that through
because when I do push it through it's
going to make those changes
um it'll kick off the pipeline I just
need to configure uh GitHub and the
repository that I've created make sure
that it has all the environments that I
want to support I want to support
development staging and production I
also need to configure the variables
that will be associated with that
repository so that it can connect to
Azure so we need things like the tenant
ID The Client app everything that oh
some secrets for SQL server admin
passwords and things like that we also
need to head off to Azure and we need to
set up some Azure ad app registration
some Federated credentials and all those
sorts of things so obviously we can't do
that very quickly unless we've got some
scripts so I've created some scripts to
do that for us
so inside of scripts we've got two
setup.ps1 and cleanup.ps1 now obviously
you shouldn't jump in and run these
scripts without understanding exactly
what they do the cleanup one is
especially destructive because it will
go and delete resources from Azure but
once you have done that and once you've
read the warning that comes up and the
disclaimer that comes up and if you type
yes it will go and do these things so I
didn't have to pass any parameters
because this script tries to figure it
out based on the environment that we
have here so I've got a couple of things
running I've got the Azure CLI running
and I've got the GitHub CLI running and
so it's able to use those tools to look
at well the GitHub repository name is
cph devfest we'll assume the project
name is cph Dev first we've got our
Azure subscription ID because I've gone
in to using the Azure CLI and actually
set the right subscription so you should
always go and do that I've got the
tenant ID the location I default it to
Australia East because that's where I am
most of the time I've got the default
SQL login SQL admin and I've got my
GitHub organization name so all of these
defaults have been collected but of
course you can pass them in as
parameters as well
and it just gives us a list of the
environments that we're going to create
and the abbreviations that it's going to
use so if I say continue
then this script is going to go off and
set up environments resources and
credentials as it says here for a
project hosted on GitHub and deployed to
Azure it'll create the workload
identities Azure ID set up resource
groups and configure environment
specific variables and secrets blah blah
blah blah it'll do all the work for us
so that's good so if I hit yes that's
going to kick off that process and so
this is something that will save me a
lot of time because if I'm starting a
new project I don't want to have to
create a new solution and start adding
files and start building tests and
installing all of my favorite packages
and I also don't want to establish the
first Pipeline and the first
infrastructure so that's what I've built
into this template I've built in the
capability that when I start a new
project based on my specialization I can
go to a client site and on day one in
the first 45 minutes I can get it
deployed through to production okay and
that means that from that point forward
I can focus on delivering business value
I can focus on building new features now
that pipeline's going to change the
infrastructure is going to change but
I've started those things from the
simplest approach possible for an
Enterprise application development okay
so it's a really good starting point
so let's see how this goes shouldn't
take too much longer let's go and have a
look in GitHub at some of the
environments and things that are being
created
so if I go into settings
and into environments here I can see the
development environment has already been
created so we've got a multi-stage
deployment in GitHub and development's
got one secret and three variables
so we can jump in here I could put some
protection rules on this Branch if I
wanted to I could set some required
reviewers so for staging and production
that's something that I definitely want
to do for development I'm just going to
let it flow through I won't do any
required reviewers as part of this
demonstration because I'll forget to do
it while we're talking about other
things and then it won't go all the way
through
so if we have a look at some of the
environment Secrets here that's a really
cool new thing in GitHub actions I don't
know how new it is but sometime this
year we got the capability for
environment specific secrets and
variables which is really really good
feature that we need so we've got the
Azure SQL administrator password the
client ID so that's the client ID for
the application in Azure ID that's
specific to the development environment
and then the resource Group name so you
can see cph Dev first and the default
SQL administrator username
so if we have a look at other
environments
we've got production staging development
they look like they're all set up so
this script is probably finished running
and so if we go over to azure
we'll see that um
resource groups and all that sort of
thing have been set up login uh I'm not
going to do that so we'll see the
resource groups have been set up they'll
be empty right now because we haven't
deployed anything but they're there
ready to receive all of the Azure
resources that were pushed through and
we'll also see an Azure ID that there's
application res
registrations for development staging
and production and also the credentials
necessary for GitHub to talk to Azure
and actually be able to deploy those
resources
so now with that done the only thing I
really have to do is push those changes
through
so that's the initial project getting
pushed through
and if we go over here
we can see fingers crossed
yep that's all pushed through and if we
go to actions
we can see the pipeline is starting to
kick off and so we're going to go into
details with the pipeline where did that
go
but for now I just want to make sure it
starts correctly
there we go yeah so it's installing.net
installing.net8 preview 7 and it'll go
through and do all the things necessary
to build and produce those artifacts
so let's tick that we'll let that tick
over keep our fingers crossed that it
goes all the way through and we'll look
at some of the features that have been
included in the template to make your
life easier
all right
I noticed this down here what I thought
I didn't I didn't really see
that was there I kind of saw it in the
back of my mind you guys should have
shouted out you've got to have my backup
here I've got to do all of these live
demos so if something doesn't look right
just let me know
all right so one of the things that I
did in this version of the template was
to improve the framework and package
management so you can see here I've got
the required.net SDK version specified
in the global.json so it's specifying
version 8 preview seven but it'll roll
forward to the latest major release
now I've also
included a directory build.props and
that specifies common props for all of
the projects in that directory so for
all of the projects dotnet8 is specified
treat warnings as errors is specified
because we don't want people committing
code with warnings in that we then have
to look at and implicit use into
nullable across all projects
and finally
I've got
directory.packages.props included so we
have Central package management and that
means that we specify our packages and
those versions in one place and then
within the Cs projects
we just specify the package without the
versions and that means if I want to say
move from net 8 preview 7 to rc1 I only
have to change one file and and the
associated packages so two files maybe
maybe one if I just ignore the fact that
my SDK is supporting an older version
but I should say
global.json is used by the CI CD
pipeline to install the appropriate SDK
as part of the build so we'd need to
change it there and then also in this
one back here so the
directory.package.props so for if I've
got you know five different test
projects and I want to go and update X
unit or end unit as the example is here
I can just change it in one file in one
place and that will update all of those
test projects so when you've got a
solution that's just one project this
sort of thing doesn't matter but when
you've got seven or eight projects
having centralized framework and package
management is really useful
all right next up dependency injection
so I'm using di with.net out of the box
but I tend to break up project service
dependencies into individual modules so
I create a extension method on iservice
collection and that way I can register
say all of the services for
infrastructure in the infrastructure
project all of the services for the
application layer in the application
project and that really helps to keep my
composition route which is program.cs
nice and Simple and Clean so you can see
there the only Services I'm registering
in program.cs are these extension
methods add application Services add
infrastructure Services pass in the
configuration and ADD web services nice
and simple much easier to maintain
all right now for the web API we've
included the API with built-in support
for asp.net core minimal API now
I didn't want to use minimal API
Straight Out of the Box because for me
it it's missing some features that I'd
really like to see one of those features
is routing conventions I don't want to
have to specify using magic strings all
of the routes and all of the names
throughout it and so I've added
extension methods to support the
defaults and routing conventions that I
would typically use
uh now there are numerous options for
organization of API endpoints and I
wanted to just discuss that so the first
option is all endpoints in a single file
such as program.cs and we see this
example a lot and it's fine if you're
building a really small application with
a tiny number of endpoints then maybe
that's going to work well for you but
generally for Enterprise application
development not so much
now you could also have individual
endpoints in separate files such as get
weather forecasts and so with this
approach all of the logic for the
endpoint is in a single file and you
might even take it a step further and
you might have a folder for that
endpoint and also put in the input types
and the response type response types and
so you have this single location where
you can go and work on that endpoint and
I think that works well for larger
applications where you have a lot of
logic in the endpoint and it makes sense
to have it all in that one place
the third approach is to group endpoints
related endpoints into a single file
such as user.cs so in user.cs I might
have the ability to log in to register
that sort of thing and this works well
again for large Enterprise applications
where there are a lot of endpoints to
manage but where there's not so much
logic in each endpoint and that pretty
much describes the type of apis that I
create they're very small very thin very
little logic and so I've decided to
group my related endpoints into a single
file now let me just show you what that
looks like so if I go over to
this one
I've got an example here of my to-do
lists and so you can see here I've
created a to-do list file inside of an
endpoints folder and so I've got to do
list to do items users and weather
forecasts I've got a um a endpoint group
base which specifies a map method we
pass in web application and then we can
use the web application to register our
endpoints so you can see here I'm
calling map group now this isn't the one
that comes out of the box the one that
comes out of the box has a few different
options but I like to actually customize
what map group does for the for the way
I typically like to build an API so this
one's an extension method so what
happens is is it will look at the type
in this case the type is to-do list and
it'll go ahead and make a group where
the base route will be API forward slash
to-do list and then it will set the
group name the group tags and specify
that these endpoints will use open AP AI
those are the defaults that I like to
use when I'm whenever I'm creating a
group of endpoints the same thing's
Happening Here require authorizations
built in because these are extension
methods right so I've extended the
capabilities of minimal API with the way
that I like to work but I haven't
reduced the capabilities so we're still
using the minimal API framework and so
we can use all of this nice fluent API
to build it up you can see with map get
this is an extension method as well so
go and put some defaults in here so
instead of specifying the name in a
magic string I'm actually getting the
name of the Handler that I'm passing
through which is get to-do lists so my
route for this particular endpoint will
be forward slash API forward slash for
to-do list forward slash get to-do lists
and so you can see that I've leveraged
minimal API and extended minimal API in
a way that makes it easy for me to work
with so I can go ahead and create one of
these groups I can use all of my
extension methods so I don't have to
write so much code and I've got the very
very small methods listed in one file
because my light doesn't live in the API
right it's often the application layer
and in the domain layer
okay
so groups are defined in separate files
they're derived from endpoint group base
which is the type that I created we
implement the map method we use the
extension methods to then register our
groups and our endpoints and then inside
of program.cs I've got another extension
method on web application which will
then just go through and automatically
wire up all of my endpoints so I just
call app.map endpoints and that's pretty
nice and clean I really like working
with it that way
all right I've also implemented the new
eye exception Handler that came with.net
8 and this allows us a mechanism for
managing
um known exception types in a kind of
controlled way so you can see here that
I've created a custom exception Handler
that is implementing the I exception
Handler interface and what it will do is
it I will add logic to handle known
exception types and if the exception is
handled by my custom logic then I'll
return true otherwise I'll return false
now typically the way that I build this
in the past was using filters but this
provides us with a really new unique
opportunity instead of handling all
known types in a single filter we can
actually have multiple exception
handlers so we can have one for not
found if that's what we're doing and one
for validation if that's what we're
doing and so what will happen is the
middleware will use these exception
handlers passing it to the next
exception Handler if the first one
doesn't handle it for us and that means
that we're able to adhere to SRP quite
closely and just have one type handled
per exception Handler so I like that
it's easy to register these exception
handlers we just go Services dot add
exception Handler
let's have a look and see how the
deployment's going
okay
still ticking along that's good news
okay so it is let's zoom in there so
it's gone through and it's done the
build it's done the validation of
infrastructure and it started the
development deployment so it's moving
through fairly well so as part of that
it's building up the infrastructure
initializing the database and deploying
the actual site
okay the template has built-in support
for open API so it'll improve your
productivity and allow you to easily
adapt to API changes so I like to
generate my open API specification on
build and it's based on the included web
API so Swagger UI is included out of the
box so you can visualize and interact
with the API endpoints and for the
angular and react templates I generate
typescript clients for those front ends
and so that means you don't have to
write your own code to interact with the
back end API in fact your front-end
developers don't even need to look at
the backend API if you've got two teams
perhaps they can just look at this
generated client it's going to include
all of the clients you'll need to
interact with the API it's going to
include Bearer tokens so authorization
is taken care of and it's also going to
include typescript versions of those
types that are exposed by your API so it
makes life really easy now the react
template was a little bit tricky to get
to work I've customized the N swag
template that has been generated and so
it supports authorization as well so you
won't need to jump through hoops to get
it to work with asp.net core Identity or
any other authorization techniques I've
also included a web.hdp file so you can
see how the API is designed to work jump
in have a play with it and get a better
understanding of it
all right next up for authentication and
authorization this is supported through
ASP netcore identity so the angular and
reacts bars use asp.net core identity UI
and cookie based Authentication
whereas the web API only apps use the
new identity API endpoints which is
excellent it comes out of the box with a
group of endpoints such as login
register refresh and we'll be able to
use those when we're building out our
angular and react apps Blazer apps
because now we don't need to rely on
that Razer UI and we don't have to build
this API ourself so in the past we kind
of maybe scaffold out the identity UI
have a look at how things are working
build an API based on that that is done
now and it's quite simple when I created
the kind of approach to minimal API for
my solution I knew when I saw this and
when I included the map identity API
that my solution was working really well
because I was able to go in and Define a
group in a really simple way and then
just call Dot map identity API which is
built by the team and it just works and
for me it looks really nice and simple
and organized so we'll see all of those
endpoints in this particular solution at
forward slash API forward slash users
and then all of the endpoints that come
with map identity API
that's an example that example is from
preview seven uh in preview eight
there's a whole host of new endpoints
that you can check out
so data access is supported using Entity
framework core either with sqlite or SQL
server but of course those are just the
options that are built into the template
if you want to go and use something else
you're free to do so as mentioned I'll
be including postgresql shortly
if core migrations is enabled and it's
almost completely automated so you still
have to go in and create migrations of
course but in development time there is
an initializer that will create the
database update it to the latest
migration and Seed the database and then
for the CI CD pipeline for all of your
deployed environments it's going to use
EF core migrations bundles so you're not
going to have to figure out how to get
that working it will build the bundle as
part of the build pipeline once the
infrastructure is deployed it will use
that bundle to upgrade your database to
the known version and of course because
it's built into the CI CD pipeline if
the bundle if the database upgrade fails
you'll know before the solution is
deployed to production and before your
user jumps on the phone and says hey
this app doesn't even start
all right so database initialization
yeah
let's see deployed environments use EF
core migrations EF core fluent apis used
to configure entities where required so
I like to keep my data model sometimes
as a dual purpose domain model I want
that to be as clean as possible so I use
the fluent API for that I've also
implemented some examples of EF core
interceptors in this template so you can
see some examples of auditing entities
and dispatching domain events
now there's a number of core features
that are built into this solution and
these are the features that are built
into the core of the architecture so
this is the application layer and the
domain layer independent of any kind of
external technology so we have automatic
validation of invoked use cases and this
is powered by mediator using the
validation behavior and fluent
validation we also have the ability to
specify authorization requirements on
use cases and that means we can go and
specify things like roles and policies
this is an abstraction that is
implemented in infrastructure on ASP
Network identity so the abstraction can
be can remain but you can change out
whatever identity process you're using
we automatically log unhandled
exceptions automatically log invoked use
cases so when you go and have a look at
that you'll see the use case name the
input for the use case and also details
of the user
we add and dispatch domain events
support for Value objects support for
auditable entities that's again powered
by EF core interceptors
and here's the CI CD pipeline let's
check and see how that's running
okay so it looks like it's finished the
deployment to development so we can
probably go and jump on and see if
that's working so if we go to deploy
website and click on that fingers
crossed
we'll come back to it give it some time
to load
okay so the cicd pipeline is a
multi-stage pipeline it's included in
the template and it's a pipeline as code
so it's built on GitHub actions so the
first thing this pipeline does is build
the solution so we saw when we had a
let's let's dive in and have a look at
that build actually
so in build here
it's going to install.net install latest
SDK restore the solution build the
solution test the solution okay
it's going to publish the website so
it's going to create that website
artifact which will then be used later
to deploy it to Azure it will also
create the EF core migrations bundle and
publish that artifact as well
so once build's done it'll kick off with
a multi-stage deployment to development
staging and production the first thing
it does is using the bicep templates is
to deploy the infrastructure now the Sim
validation that happens on those bicep
templates before they run so you do have
an opportunity to actually if you put in
some required approvers you have an
opportunity to review the changes that
will be made to Azure if you click
approve and continue so that's why
you're seeing some additional steps in
here so for the deploy to development
there was a validate stage to check
those templates and a deploy stage for
the deploy to staging there was a
validate stage which was running a
what-if so we can go and have a look at
the changes that will be made if we
decide to go ahead with this deployment
okay so there's the dev environment up
and running and ready to go so not much
to see there it's an API but it was a
successful deployment
okay so the continuous delivery pipeline
will deploy the infrastructure and then
initialize the database so the
initialize of the database is happening
using the EF core migrations bundle and
just for clarity the migrations bundle
is a cross-platform application that
will upgrade your database to the
correct migration and you don't have to
manage that and then finally it will
deploy the website
now the infrastructure as code AS
mentioned has been built using bicep
templates now I've based this on the
Azure reference architecture for a basic
web application because I figured we
need the simplest starting point before
we dive into the details and figure out
actually what is this application going
to be about is it multi-tenanted let's
get something up and running so we can
start building features and we'll start
to evolve the CI CD Pipeline and the
infrastructure as code from a place that
works right and that's important we've
got something that works and we can
build on it as we understand more
so you can see there we'll have an app
service plan with an app we've got a SQL
Server database and we've got
application insights wired up and
receiving metrics across those services
now there's also support for code
scaffolding so when you installed the
template you've got of course the ca
solution template which is a.net Project
template for building the solution but
you also receive the ca use case
template and so this template is
something you typically run from within
the application directory where the
application project lives this is where
we create the use cases the reason that
this application exists an example of
use cases might be dispatching an order
or creating a new customer
so we run it by going.net new ca use
case and there's a number of options
that we can specify so first thing is
the feature name and that will go ahead
and create a feature folder in the
application directory if it doesn't
exist then we have the use case type
either a command or query because in
this approach we're using cqrs and next
we have the name which is the name of
the use case being created so let's give
some examples so the feature name might
be orders and the use case name might be
dispatch order and then finally we have
the return type which is optional
depending on what type of use case
you're creating so as an example here
we've got net new Co use case feature
name of orders
use case type of command and name of
dispatch order and so that'll give us a
nice skeleton that we can get started
with and go and start adding our
application logic to that skeleton
finally documentation so when you create
a new template when you create a new
solution using the template it includes
a readme file which is generated
automatically and is based on the
version of the template that you created
so if you create an angular app a react
app or a web API on the app it'll be
specific to that and it includes steps
basic tasks such as building and running
the app
code scaffolding to generate use cases
details on code Styles and formatting
using editor config running the
automated tests and help and other
resources it also includes the version
of the template that was used to create
the solution so if at some point you
want to go back to the clean
architecture solution template and look
at what's new and what has changed
you'll have a point at which you can
compare that
all right let's have a look and see how
our deployment's going
okay so it looks like it's in the final
stages now so it's going through and
deploying to production
check in there so yes it's finished uh
it's finished the initial stages it's
deploying infrastructure then it'll go
through and initialize the database
before finally deploying the website so
it looks like that's going to be
successful
which is good
so it's been running for 22 minutes now
so that means that you know if we're on
client site first day on the job it's
9am
this is going to be finished within the
uh 45 minutes at least and we'll be able
to grab a coffee before the kickoff
meeting which is nice so I like to
operate
whoops
all right thank you for coming to my
talk today I hope you've enjoyed it now
if you'd like to learn more you can jump
onto github.com at jasontaylordev clean
architecture and there you can learn
more about the template you can request
a new feature request a bug fix and you
can have conversations with other people
contributors and users about the
template and how best to use it if you
do find the template to be useful I'd
really appreciate it if you give it a
start on GitHub thank you
[Applause]
uh plenty of time for questions if
anyone has any
yep
into sorry why do I separate them into
separate
um two reasons so so why do I append
kind of the name of the yes that's right
so the question was in the minimal API
approach let's see I'm going to bring up
the card
so
actually maybe we can even just go to
Swagger UI
okay so the question is why do I append
the name of the method to the route is
that right so you can see there that I'm
not
um really what's happening is the name
of the method is being used to provide a
richer set of data to API Explorer so
that when it goes and builds the
specification it's going to be able to
build us a nice open API specification
and it's going to organize things into
those groups so you can see there we've
got a grouping of our to-do items to-do
lists and users actually we can come
here and see all of the wonderful
endpoints that the team has put in for
working with asp.net core identity
they've really gone above and beyond I
don't I don't know if we'll see any more
as part of the.net 8 release because I
think it'll be about stabilization now
with rc1 and rc2 but that's a really
great starting point
any other questions
yes
sorry I can't you'll have to come
forward sorry
yes that's a good question so thank you
for using the template
um so the upgrade of the template how do
we do that there's no supported upgrade
process and when I generated the readme
that I showed you before the reason that
I put the version in there is so that
you always know what version the
solution was created from so the
simplest thing you could do to see
what's new is go back and install that
version of the template create a new
empty solution and then install the
latest version create a new empty
solution and compare the two that at
least is going to give you an idea of
what's new but you can also go through
and check the release notes because when
I do a new release I try to describe
what's changed so you could dive in and
grab those things that you're interested
in
yeah it's not an easy easy problem to
solve but at least if you know the
version it was created from you've got a
good starting point a reference point
yes
that's a great question are there any
plans to add Blazer to the template I've
been very busy working on this one but I
do have a Blazer template and this one
is for Blazer webassembly
so oh we're about to run out of time
so it's called rapid Blazer it's on.net7
and one of the things that I'll be doing
next is fixing that failing build and
deploy but after that I'll be upgrading
it to.net 8 as well so the rapid Blazer
template is simpler uh is is similar
it's got a built-in CI CD pipeline it's
got built-in
infrastructure as code templates and uh
what else does it have it's got some
scripts to help you get started but it's
not quite as easy so I'll need to take
what I've learned all the changes that
I've made to the clean architecture
solution template and apply it to Rapid
Blazer
and it's starting to get tricky because
now I've got too many open source
projects to maintain so if you do have
some time and you are interested and
you'd like to contribute I'd welcome
some contributions if you're not sure
where to start you can ask me and we can
figure out a good place to start
any other questions yes
foreign
that's a great question do I have any
plans to extend the template to use
Azure devops pipelines as well as GitHub
actions yeah you know something that's
really interesting me at the moment is
the Azure developer CLI and they're
doing a lot of great work and I'd like
to see how much I can Leverage The Azure
developer CLI as part of this template
so then I would have a net project
template that uses the Azure developer
CLI the table to deploy GitHub actions
pipelines Azure devops pipelines
by bicep templates or terraform
templates and I think that might be a
good starting point but I worry that
it's not going to support a multi-stage
pipeline so I'm tracking some of the
issues on that repository to see if
they're adding support for that so I
will add support for Azure devops
pipelines pretty soon it's not a it's
not a big task but I'm not sure whether
it'll come through Azure developer CLI
or directly into the template
yes
so could you ask again
no but I'd so uh what about gitlap am I
planning to add support for CI CD for
gitlab no I'm not planning to add
support but I would welcome a
contribution on that
um so
for me an open source project building
in my spare time I tend to focus on the
things that I do and so for me that's
Azure devops pipelines and GitHub
actions but if you if somebody puts
through a contribution forget lab that
would be appreciated and I'd definitely
include it in the template
any last questions
okay wonderful thanks again everyone bye